ryan yarbrough making the third start of
the season
taking them out here tonight a great job
of mixing his pitches
and a cut in the miz pilar out on
strikes to start this game
sander hitting 297 with three home runs
[Applause]
this one stays down at third for diaz
and the throw right there to martinez no
run to hit the man left martin perez
looking to make it back to back strong
outings red sox really need that tonight
against tampa bay
i fly ball into right center verdugo's
gonna go to the wall and that one is
over his glove bounds back to pavar into
second goes diaz who didn't miss a home
run by much that ball had great carry
early chance here for the race
and the strike wow got him a little
debate there silently by martinez that's
on number two first and second for mike
rosso hitters count for brussel
hits that one hard and nice play by
devers he'll go to the back for the
force and retire the side tampa bay
failing to score
willie adamus back in the lineup after a
day off
ground ball
third defers down to second one first
they complete the double play
swing and a mess he's out of there and
the rays are finished into second
hereby draws an opening walk here yandy
diaz up here
ground ball headed to second
out there and across the back comes
bogart with his throw to first in time
four six three on the double play this
this so far has been a typical rhino bro
start here's michael chavis with two
outs in the bases at the end yarborough
ready here's the pitch to chavis
swinging a little looper in the center
field he's two for two as he's been able
to square up yarborough a couple of
times so the red sox have a base runner
off yarbrough in front of alex paduco
get out of here high fly ball deep right
field driving back renfro at the wall
and that ball is out of here it's gone
there's number one for alex verdugo
he hits a two-run homer and touches them
all here at tropicana field and the red
sox have the lead in the fourth inning
we've been waiting for him to go hit a
ball in the air and he does off a
left-handed pitcher jose martinez will
open the home half of the fourth
that's a shot toward right center extra
base is coming for martinez rolling all
the way to the wall my team is on his
way to second base with the stand-up
double so two outs so after runners at
first and second nobody out couple of
unproductive outs and now here's willie
adams trying to pick him up payoff pitch
from the lefty
he struck him out
well right there on the high wire again
but he's going to strand two
down by a couple runs two to nothing
jonathan aroused the second baseman
is out number one great job right there
by ryan yarbrough tying up
jonathan rahu's two out base
runner he got a nice job by
ryan yarbrough to take care of martinez
yandi open to first with a double
eyeball left center field that ball will
drop in there cut off on the track pilar
and it's going to be a double for diaz
it's austin meadows popped out and it'll
fly ball to center
glide into right field and verdugo to
close on this one and once again perez
pitching around the doubles still two
nothing socks
xander has grounded out he's also lined
up he's going to fly this one deep karen
meyer back to the wall he can't get it
it's off the fence
xander to second base
take a bit of a turn and he'll settle
for the double
here's another one and vasquez rips it
into left field off the glove of the
third baseman diaz that's a base hit
bogarts will trot home and score vasquez
will hold at first it's an rbi single
and the red sox lead it three to nothing
chavis already has two michael is two
for two
there's a shot
high deep drive into left center back it
goes and that's gone chavis for the
second time this season is third hit
tonight and it's five nothing red sox
took the guy out the little poster out
there in left center sox trying to put
this one into the win column sitting
pretty at 5-0 over tampa bay brandon
workman coming on to lock it up all
right here is rosso
there's that hook swinging to miss
struck him out one gun red sox one out
away sends up a domus who's gone over
three and the o2
see ya drills it in there and that will
do it that's a tidy win
red sox beating tampa bay five to
nothing